This is Molly and Sam Gelman. How long have you been married?
63 years.
We met at a party...
No.
...downstairs in the basement.
No. We went to lunch.
It took me right before New Year's. And then, all of a sudden, the phone rang.
I said, "Who is it?"
"It's Sam Gelman." At New Year's day, he wanted a date.
I said, "No, I'm tired. I'm going to rest and I'll see you another time."
He really looked terrible.
So, was it love at first sight?
Not at all.
But I figured I'd give him another chance.
Right.
Go.
We met on a corner of...
What street?
Church Avenue.
Church at Flatbush Avenue.
I know it well.
And there's a restaurant right on the corner.
On the corner of that restaurant.
How beautiful was she?
She was gorgeous.
I was.
And we went into the restaurant.
And, what do you know, we went into the restaurant right on the corner.
I can't think of the name of the restaurant.
But it was a...
Dairy.
It was actually a cafeteria.
Thank you so much!